joining us now on the program the
culture secretary nadine doris minister
great to have you on the program this
morning and and we have an awful lot to
talk about in terms of your own briefing
and the online safety bill and i promise
we will we will definitely come to that
but but i do want to start with with the
resignation um of nick gibb a minister
well a former minister of course not
someone known for rocking the boat for
throwing toys out of the pram when he
says that the prime minister accepted
the resignation of allegra stratton for
joking about a christmas party that she
hadn't attended but he wouldn't take
responsibility for those he did attend
mr gibb has a point doesn't he
um sorry did you say the resignation of
nick gibb
i so sorry yes sorry yeah the the letter
of no confidence you're absolutely right
okay so um so look there are 365
conservative mps and i can promise you
that the vast vast majority of those mps
97 of them will be out in their
constituencies today who are delivering
on the promises that they made to their
constituents and boris johnson has made
to them and you know i i understand why
the media do this and of course it has
to be reported but the number of mps who
are
former ministers remainers um those who
have called for both
theresa may david cameron and every
prime minister to go in the conservative
party
they they of course do make um they are
you know it's disappointing what nick
nick has done but i i'm very
disappointed because i've known nick for
many years but what i would say is this
is not this is of absolute minority in
the conservative party because boris
johnson delivered and most mps know that
the biggest majority since margaret
thatcher he has continued to deliver
in those red wall and northern
constituencies booster rollout program
biggest in europe
we've got the we've got the fastest
growing economy in the g7 and it's so
many so much delivered both in funding
to those marginal seats and i would say
it's okay for you know those mps who've
got safe you know majorities and what
they would describe as safe seats but
those mps out in those marginal seats
are working incredibly hard and they do
make up the vast majority of the
conservative party but you cannot tell
me that you have not had messages from
constituents raising legitimate concerns
indeed you yourself may have had a
couple of moments over the past couple
of years the same as the rest of us when
we have found ourselves limiting our
behavior because of the rules that were
in place you must have had done that
yourself and perhaps even looked at what
happened at number 10 and and maybe
rolled your eyes slightly
so i would say you know the biggest
inbox of complaints i had were about
dominic cummings and his trip to barnard
castle one of what i've had now is
absolutely and the prime minister
defended that one to the hilt
i've had nothing like on the scale
of that over reason and you know what
people really i think perhaps now do
understand is that downing street may
have an iconic front door and it may be
you know a very nice building but it's
actually a department with 400 people
working inside downey street it's an
office it's a workplace it's like a
school it's like a teacher's staff room
it's like it is a workplace it's not a
home base and and i think that
distinction needs to be made
but when you look at the what have been
what has been said by some of the most
senior members of government including
amongst that number rishi sooner and
sajid javid both of whom have distanced
themselves by some margin from the
comments that the prime minister made in
relation to zakir stammer and and jimmy
savile this is not some isolated
criticism coming from the back benches
this is criticism that is being made by
the man who lives next door in the
office next door
i spoke to sanjay javid last night and
he reassured me and that he is 100
percent behind the prime minister in
fact i think he's quite shocked at how
his comments have been interpreted and
you know i think you only need something
sorry sorry mister sorry to interrupt
but what does it say about the party
right now that you had to go and ask the
health secretary whether or not he
supported the prime minister
i didn't go and ask the health secretary
you know as cabinet ministers who are
passing through a huge amount of
legislation we talk all the time but it
was last night when this the comments
supposed comments that sajid jaffar was
saying were were on the media and
obviously they came up and he is 100
what you're reporting about sajid javid
turning his back on the prime minister
is not true he is 100 behind the prime
minister i i didn't suggest he turned
his back on him 100 what i did suggest
was that he had looked at the remarks
that the prime minister made in relation
to sarkir starmer and jimmy savile and
ultimately said you know what i wouldn't
have done that now that is from a very
senior man a very senior figure former
chancellor now health secretary dealing
with the public health strategy as
regards covet this isn't some random
backbencher saying
so
i'm not a random backbencher either and
my perspective on this is that when you
lead an organisation such as the prime
minister leads the government you have
to take responsibility for actions and
decisions taken by that organization
kierstarma took responsibility by
apologizing in 2013 for what happened in
the cps during the jimmy savile
investigation now my perspective is that
kiestama apologized he took
responsibility for what happened in the
same way any leader of any organization
takes responsibility was he to blame
then
he took responsibility in the same way
the prime minister take if you lead an
organization the buck stops with you you
are responsible for the actions of that
organization kierstarma apologized quite
clearly in 2013 for what happened in the
cps during the jimmy savile
investigation when he was director of
public prosecutions in the same way the
prime minister goes to the dispatch box
and he takes responsibility for what
happens in this government yeah so it is
it was secure star wars fault then just
going back what you said there it wasn't
i said
i was very clear with my words
kia stammer took responsibility for the
investigation in the cps into jimmy
savile and he apologized in 2013
for what had happened during that
investigation what was darma
quite rightly
took responsibility
for the for what had happened during
that investigation
i mean we should we should not gloss
over the fact that of course there have
been a number of resignations this week
some of which can technically be linked
to sue gray's update and and the
metropolitan police investigation the
one that kant is the head of the policy
unit maniro mirza who left number 10
suggesting that the prime minister would
better have apologized straight away to
not just issue a clarification for those
remarks but apologize for them she even
described them as a scuttleous
i
you know i've worked with manira i like
manira very much that was manira's point
of view i have just articulated to you
my point of view which is different
well let's dwell on your brief then uh
ms doris because you have been good to
give us the time this morning and the
online safety bill you heard um
you heard your opposite number uh lucy
powell in the introduction to you
talking on a different topic but when
asked about the online safety bill
suggest she suggested that the labour
party you know broadly support it and
you know acknowledge that it is a fairly
sizable piece of legislation what are
the biggest changes that you're hoping
to make through this
other a considerable number of changes
you know i've been in this pace four
months and when i arrived
in the department
the bill i couldn't take the bill
through as it was because it didn't
achieve those really serious fundamental
objectives such as protecting children
and protecting adults from harm in in so
many ways i don't think any of us know
anyone who hasn't had a completely
adverse
experience with online platforms and
it's what we've announced today is a
list of priority offences which will be
on the face of the bill and that is
listening to the recommendations of the
the joint committee and the dcms
subcommittee and we've listed those
priority offences but also taken into
account three new offenses which have
been recommended by the law commission
you know some of those offences will um
those those
those recommendations actually cover
people like footballers um celebrities
presenters mps who frequently receive
abuse abuse rape threats
violence threats of violence murder so
many i mean too much to mention and so
there's a whole new raft of measures but
i would just say today is the
announcement of the new criminal
sanctions a whole third of this bill
more of this bill is protected just
dedicated just to protecting children
there'll be more on that forthcoming but
i will be taking this bill to the house
in a few weeks
just in terms of those those additional
offences and one of the points that lucy
powell made was not included in in the
latest advice from the dcms was perhaps
an effect an offense of you know
promoting or encouraging self-harm we
know that that is a big issue among
younger people particularly she also
suggested that cyber flashing was not
included as well
well what i would say is lucy hasn't
seen the bill so she doesn't know what's
in the bill uh you you only know what
we've announced today in terms of the
latest uh raft of criminal offences so
certainly cyber
will cyber flag
be in there and promotion or
encouragement of self-harm
so both cyber flashing um is with the
ministry of justice and is being
considered now and actually i just want
to give a shout out to maria miller mp
who's done a huge amount of work on this
that is being considered by the moj
right now and um hopefully the work will
be done on that and also um sorry and
the other the other offensive self-harm
we're also considering that too that's
also into consideration at the moment so
you know work is still ongoing at the
moment we've changed this bill
dramatically in four months from what it
was just a few months ago it has changed
it's it's extensive and it's
wide-ranging and we are leading the
world on this the rest of the world is
watching to see what we do so we have to
get it right but all of those things you
know we have included today prevention
of those algorithms which direct young
people and adults towards suicide chat
rooms those which is
which is very significant but self-harm
i understand and we're looking at that
and cyber flashing too
um just in terms of of the work that is
that is clearly ongoing on this bill you
yourself said you'd be introducing it in
a few weeks
when might this become law then
as soon as possible i mean there is a
period of time the bill will come to the
house it will go into committee stage it
will have third reading and then it will
we will go into the queue to receive
royalists and that's out of our hands
then but hopefully as soon as possible
well i'm just asking you maybe give us a
bit more direction than kind of about
how long's a piece of string i mean i i
understand the desire to get it done as
soon as possible but are we talking
about within 24 months within 12 months
within two oh yeah
definitely more than sooner than 24
months i mean a piece of legislation
once it passes sorry about my dogs by
the way a piece of legislation once it
passes through the commons usually takes
about 12 months to to receive royal
assent
ascent
one of the things that when when looking
at the the the work that had been done
this morning that kind of left out to me
and the words that you yourself have
written was are you want to restrict the
ability of of silicon valley to limit
free nervous speech just explain exactly
what you what what you mean by that i
mean
are you talking about stopping private
companies from doing what they want on
their own platforms
so
so private companies such as facebook
meta instagram though those were there
is user generated content and where we
know the greatest number of harms takes
place they won't be able to put whatever
they want on their platforms once this
law happens no they won't be able to
there will be and actually what we're
doing today by listing those priority
offenses and by
um announcing the recommendations from
the law commission which we're accepting
as new criminal sanctions what we're
doing is saying here you go
facebook meta instagram here's here's
what you're going to be facing in the uk
when this becomes law you have the power
now to remove those harmful algorithms
you have the powers now to change what
you're doing which is causing so much
harm and so many problems so no you're
absolutely right
those organizations won't be able to do
just what they want anymore and but
there are carve outs so publishers
broadcasters like yourself newspapers
they are not included in the bill
you you will have noticed i'm sure and
the comments are the joke that is that
has caused some consternation one from
jimmy carr relates to the traveling
community relates to the holocaust
is that the type of material that this
bill would be
would be able to target
so no because um those shocking comments
were made by jimmy carr on netflix i
believe over a year ago actually and and
though so it doesn't but what i would
say is that the another bill that we
have um to come through is
a media bill which we are looking at
including those video on demand
streaming organizations such as netflix
we're looking at including those into
into the scope of that bill to make the
kind of comments that jimmy carr made
which i believe were a year ago um also
um subject to
uh
a new law which will impose sanctions
upon those organizations
is there any part of you you know as a
conservative as someone you know who you
know you think of kind of traditional
values traditionally associated with
conservatism and the conservative party
is there any part of you that is worried
that we are coming you know close and
circumstances such as that to curtailing
free speech
no absolutely not we've been very very
care well because i'm a conservative
i've been very very careful about that
and we are
certainly what we're looking at is if
you call free speech you know
encouraging young people to take their
own lives or threatening to rape or
murder someone or
um
stalkers you know posting photographs of
their street signs to their victims
while they're on their street if you
call that free speech i call that
harmful speech and what we're doing in
this bill we have kind of three buckets
one is bringing
into into this bill everything which is
illegal already offline we're making it
illegal online and we will be protecting
children that's a whole section of the
bill and also looking at ways of
bringing in behaviors which are legal
but harmful which is
some of the measures that i've mentioned
uh during this interview today it's a
wide-ranging bill as i've said the rest
of the world is watching to see what we
do because you know 10 years we had 10
years of the internet kind of having its
own way to now but as i've said we've
seen some of the harms that are
happening particularly to young people
and adults within our society and it's
time now for us to do something about
that and that's why we're bringing this
bill forward
uh well minister uh we have to let you
go we've kept you longer than we should
but i did want to give a decent amount
of time to the online safety bill so
thank you dean doris we'll see you again